hi everybody
welcome back to your online graduation
so before we get started with
last week i wanted to introduce you to a
very special little book which you
should have received already or will be
receiving
hopefully very very soon in your class
day in a box package that nathan spoke
about
it's called the class anthology and in
it is a series of reflections written by
members of the class of 2020
there's some space at the front for you
to record your own thoughts and
reminisces
and many black pages at the back feed
together messages from your friends when
we're all able to be together again
this isn't how any of us imagined we
would end our time as undergrads
but my hope is that you'll be able to
relate to some of the feelings expressed
in the class anthology
and hold on to it as a memento of a
significant time in our lives
and now i have the honor
of introducing the first speech of our
program
traditionally the serious reflection is
given to commemorate the experience of
just being a yearly
our four years here were you know full
of ups and downs
which makes a serious reflection all the
more important as the speaker challenges
us to find meaning
in our experiences at yale in spite of
all the differences that we might have
had
and all the challenges we may have faced
so it is with
great happiness that i am proud to
present
the serious reflection this year given
by joy chu
of ezra styles
hi class of 2020 we're graduating this
week
not in a way that we ever expected but
we are graduating nonetheless
there will be no frantic packing of bags
there will be no final tearful goodbyes
no one is going to walk across any stage
but in six days time we will nonetheless
officially become a part of yale's
history trading in our identities
as current students to emerge as
graduates of the yale college class of
2020
in these unprecedented times in the
complete absence of traditions we hold
dear what does it really mean
to graduate
in more ways than just physically covet
19 has uprooted our class
it disintegrated our expectations for a
joyous and bittersweet senior spring
it dissolved a sense of constancy and
stability we never even knew we were
taking for granted
for many of us this pandemic has
introduced uncertainty
hardship and tragedy into our lives
without diminishing the gravity of the
situation i find
comfort in the fact that our time at
yale means
more than the 1 16 that coronavirus
stole
it's hard not to let the ending color
the journey
but these past few weeks cannot and
should not fundamentally change
what yale means to us and what it has
meant to us for the better part of the
past
four years and what
does yale mean the onus is on us
now more than ever to reflect and find
what matters
what does it mean to be a yeli
what brings our class together beyond
the emotional bond
forged from the pain of loss what do we
all share
my answer not as much as you might think
admittedly we're all human and now more
educated and privileged
but the idea that we're unified or
similar in some
fundamentally yale way
is a myth
let me tell you a story about the aacc
the asian american cultural center
the acc is a place i met some of my very
best friends where i spent countless
hours planning events for the chinese
american students association
the aacc is a place i found new ways to
celebrate my identity
at lunar ball and hop hot night eating
sticky rice and writing calligraphy
without a doubt the aacc has been one of
the most integral parts of my yale
experience
at the end of my junior year i like many
of you decided to join a senior society
as is customary at initiation we all
gathered around in a circle and shared
intimate parts of our lives with each
other
i chose to talk about the aacc and
everything that it's meant to me
and that night for the very first time i
met
someone who didn't know what the aacc
was
and for a moment i was speechless amazed
that this
this formative and vibrant community so
personal to me
could be completely foreign to him and
to any yeely really because to me
yale isn't yale without the aacc
but my conception of yale is just that
it's mine and just as my friend didn't
know what the aacc
is i had no idea what yale looks like
for someone
training to become a professional
athlete next year for someone who lives
close enough to drive home for a weekday
dinner
or for someone who meditates almost
every day inside the buddhist shrine in
harkness tower
and even the words we use does foot
bring to mind
inches or the appalachian trail when you
hear
zoo do you think reprinting
and when i say aacc do you think
home it's realizations like these that
make me fully appreciate the different
lives that people here lead
and it's these realizations that
convince me
believing that we all could share
something anything
real that has to be a myth
maybe it's hard to believe me when i say
that because if you picture the friends
and classmates you've been zooming
week in and week out and think about the
intersections of your lives
your shared experiences will feel so
salient and so
real i don't doubt that
there's the 10 or so people you've lived
with the 50 or 100 friends you've made
through extracurriculars
and the hundreds more you've met in
class at the gym
waiting in line at the dining hall
but the truth is there are probably
almost a thousand of you in the class of
2020
that i've never had the pleasure of
exchanging a single word with
and whatever yale means to me whatever
spaces i've inhabited
there are parts of your yale experiences
that i can't
possibly begin to conceive of
sure it means something to be a yeli
it means that in 15 years when you
encounter someone who also went to yale
you can squabble over the best
residential college or laugh about zoom
university
you can reminisce about our wins at
harvard yale or your favorite jihab
sandwich
or how pretty sterling looks at winter's
first snowfall
but the truth is aside from
participating in these same
yale traditions and sharing in some of
these more surface level memories
our lived experiences at yale are so
wildly different
and it would be a bit misguided to
believe that there is some
core quality about being a yeah that
unites us all
the truth is there isn't
this may seem depressing
but it's not this perspective is
actually kind of
uplifting because the alternative to
believing that we share
nothing in common would be to believe
that yale is so
seductive that four years here is enough
to hammer parts of our identities into
shapes completely indistinguishable from
each other
as an institution yale sells us a
version of
the good life things that we should
value things like
prestige academic excellence
professional success
productivity critical thinking and civil
discourse
these can all be good things they can
but it would be so so horrible if we all
journey through yale like sponges
absorbing these skills and values and
personality traits
so that when we emerge on the other end
we've lost the fibers of who we once
were and are
similar enough so saturated with things
that are
classically mainstream yale
that i could stand here and give a
speech today about what unites us all
it's uplifting to believe that there's
infinitely more that distinguishes and
unites us
because it means that we made conscious
choices in
occupying the spaces that we did
to put this more concretely i want you
to take a moment and think about
who we were as pre-frosh probably
excited
and also hopeful at one of the most
certain and also uncertain points of our
lives
as pre-frosh we had a set of
expectations for what yale would be like
we had ambitions and passions we had
hopes and fears
we came to yale with an established
identity and belief system
standing here today i can tell you that
i failed to meet some of my expectations
i did things that surprised myself i had
incredible experiences and made friends
and memories that i wouldn't trade
for the world but the thing that feels
most personal to tell is that i'm not
the same person i was
four years ago and maybe that's obvious
because because it is obvious but it's
also the most
important thing to reflect on
what stayed since you were a prefrosh
and what hasn't
because of yale i am more in touch with
my heritage
i am less afraid of being judged for
what i like and don't like
i know better what kinds of adventures
i'd find fulfilling
standing here today my identities and
values have been
amplified and altered and challenged and
enriched
because of yale and the experiences i
had
the same is true for all of us
yale gave us more than just access to a
set of traditions and privilege
a claim to the term yeli
yale gave us the opportunity to find a
fuller more authentic version of
ourselves
no matter how long it took for yale to
feel like home
whether you spent your nights piece
setting in bass or dancing in toads or
laughing till your sides hurt in styles
f41
the chosen and eclectic experiences
we've had at this institution
have fundamentally changed who we are
without
compromising who we are
so what's the point
i have no right to stand here and
generalize about all of our collective
experiences
because they were all different and
hopefully they were experiences we
pursued with intention that we had the
agency to choose
and as those experiences tried to change
us hopefully we fought to become better
versions of ourselves
with greater conviction in who we are
and the things we value
so in 15 years when this pandemic is far
behind us
and you're thinking back to your bright
college
years don't just be proud to be a yali
be proud of the person that yale shaped
you to become
thank you